lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
[Music]
a children's show that's not impressive
well for you to do order though i didn't
i did too but i didn't mean to that's
how good i am tom medium when there's
two you can only get in the right order
though because any way you look at it
since there's only two the order's right
a children's show so when you when you
have two the only thing you can do is
get it in the right order pro but when
you have three
it's really takes skill when you have
three it takes skill
that's so bad do you have skill
i have skill
children's show um
okay well that's good man i'm glad you
have skill
skill throwing up
welcome to the show lifeline
uh and we are already rip roaring aren't
we yeah um i've got my join our cult
and share ideas merch on for over at
congratulations and welcome to lifeline
brought to you by super cult studios the
coldest tasting beer
um do you remember when they did that in
coors life
no
okay well they did it the coldest
tasting beer oh when they were doing the
silver bullet [ __ ] doesn't matter rock
the rockies i don't know rocky mountain
high colorado
why did they do it like it was a
commercial for colorado
well is that a real song already
i don't know
yeah i guess it maybe is but i remember
um my friend tim would when i was in
high school that that commercial came
out for coors light and it would be like
rocky mountain high colorado and and he
would he would say i had we were friends
with a guy named brandon and he would
say rocky mountain hi chris and brandon
and i don't know why and it pissed me
off and i think about it sometimes tim
oh
yeah i talk about him in the past few
episodes of congratulations and also now
lifeline so that's great tim chung yep i
haven't thought about tim chung once
since the last time i saw his face which
was probably when i was a [ __ ]
freshman in high school sadiq
about tim chong no i'm just saying
that's crazy i've seen memory lane i
said i've seen him okay
so uh yeah you can get the merch over
here at crystalline.com but also super
cool uh lifelines
brought to you by
super cult studios
the coldest tasting beer why do you do
that um because i remember it and i want
to do it that's not a good reason um and
so i'm going to be why don't i do dates
i'm going to be in your boys going on
tour you know that i'm going to be in
grim
grimpering throughout almost
grand prairie texas and that's near
dallas in case you don't know but you
probably know if you're in texas so i'm
going to be in grand prairie texas
august 26th wichita kansas
august 27th did you know wichita is
where the btk killer's from did you know
yes i did do you know which is how it
makes me think about uh shut your mouth
and then i think about wwf slam down
shut your mouth
smackdown shut your mouth i don't know
what i mean slam down you know so far
what is uh wrestling shows uh slam down
what is shut your
wwe smack down shut your mouth okay
yeah smackdown shut your mouth is the
dopest [ __ ] thing to call it well it
really is dude smackdown shut your mouth
would be a rapper you know that right
yeah okay
so uninviting you know yo what up it's
smackdown shut your mouth
yeah that's gonna get you don't get a
good rapper get your head down get your
head out you play put out your ass play
with it oh secure well rappers are
insecure dude okay so uh
wwe smackdown shut your mouth why did
the wwf had to change it to wwe do you
know why i know why because they needed
to legally say that it was entertainment
and when it was an f standing for
federation it wasn't clear that it was
not real that it was [ __ ] fake so
they changed it to an e to make sure
that we all knew it was entertainment
none of that's true but um yeah i might
have made that that's not true that's
not true at all yeah okay well i think i
thought
they changed the company uh because of
how they uh there was something else
called the same thing
but it's fine but it's fiction but it's
it's good like harry potter is good yeah
is it good no um harry potter i thought
we'll get into that later so i'm gonna
be in atlanta georgia wichita kansas uh
hotbed of crime gonna be there atlanta
georgia washington dc hotbed of
political crime september 10th
stockton california and then oakland
california september 23rd september 24th
hotbed of crime yep get your wig split
back uh peoria illinois near chicago
hotbed of crime rockford illinois near
chicago hotbed of crime uh that's
october 7th october 8th raleigh north
carolina that's where the guy from the
staircase through his [ __ ] wife
downstairs better crime savannah georgia
pretty nice but probably uh probably a
better crime for the horses and cows
upscale crime yeah yeah yeah exactly
dude white collar crime yep uh then
denver colorado november 5th cheyenne
wyoming november 6th beautiful mountains
boston massachusetts november 12th two
shows how about irish crime
[Laughter]
hot pedestal into potatoes and guinness
um and then december 2nd and 3rd i'm
going to be in lakeland florida and
jacksonville florida hot better
incestual crime so um
anyway dude i'll be there go to
chrisleya.com and get your tickets
they're flying and crystalia.com brought
to you by the coldest tasting beer
we're gonna stop doing that no we don't
i think we are we keep doing the same
thing over and over again and now that i
have a kid i do the same thing over and
over again and i have an audience that
appreciates it thank god yeah yep he
loves it he doesn't even have to say do
it again daddy you finally have someone
who likes it yep so um [ __ ]
two-year-old yeah so i saw harry potter
you saw harry potter saw the first two
ones and i'm on the third one you would
just the other day say and that trigger
the other game chris was saying i don't
know [ __ ] anything about harry potter
i don't know all of a sudden you're
saying you've seen the first three let
me tell you this i saw
two harry potters and a half two and a
half harry potters
two harry potters and the half okay
harry putters what the third one wasn't
cutting it or what no i i fell asleep
because i wasn't cutting it but it was
late oh okay um i don't i don't know
what it's about there said it and you
don't either yes dude and everyone says
it's so good and i don't know what it's
about and here's even more i don't know
how to describe what it's about
yes dude it's impossible
you're a [ __ ] idiot dude you've see
there's eight of the movies watch it and
you've seen two and a half of them and
you don't know what it's it's about kids
in a school that no magic and then they
learn magic and then also there's evil
there i guess and a guy is like trying
to come back to life and he keeps trying
to come back to life and the kids like
don't like them but some of the kids do
that's exactly how jk rowling pitched it
dude i don't know what it's about
well then you're stupid fantastic beasts
i watched [ __ ] some of it it's by jk
rowling it's by just kidding railings do
you know what do you know what that's
about yes it's about a guy who [ __ ]
tries to
uh collect all the beasts because the
beasts get out in the city and the beast
can't be known because the beasts are in
the underworld and he's like this
liaison between the beast world and the
regular world and he can't figure out
how to get him and he has to get them
all back
here's what before everyone feels
realizes that the beast here's what i
don't like
and i haven't even seen it any of this
[ __ ]
based on jk rowling's books just kidding
rallings makes books that are about
crazy [ __ ] dude they just keep on
making up rules i'm watching it with
kristin i'm like
that yeah i'm like so wait
why does why why is he now over here and
she's like because this is the land
where everything's okay and yeah he just
has to ask for help and then he gets it
there's always a land where that thing's
open and i'm like what everything else
is not okay everywhere else this is a
[ __ ] movie this is why a lot of the
sci-fi [ __ ] is [ __ ] because you
don't need
to actually
write good [ __ ] because you can just
like it it's like if a [ __ ] movie was
a
um
a regular movie not with [ __ ] sci-fi
and then all of a sudden in this movie
they were like oh well but here's the
[ __ ] actual mechanism that if you
press a button everyone forgets
everything and then they can move on
with their lives
that's just but they're making it do you
know what i'm saying or no
like you're saying the right way to say
what you're saying is if you don't set
up the world clearly at the beginning
it sucks
sci-fi is yes a slippery slope because
you can just keep making [ __ ] up keep
making [ __ ] up in the middle and then
the end and be like well this thing
needs to happen [ __ ] i wrote myself into
a corner ah what if i make up this part
where that in la land you could do that
one thing yeah it's all mechanisms and
tricks like even men in black it's like
oh we can wipe your memory boom and it's
also like here come the men in black
galaxy defenders is that what they say
the galaxy defenders yeah i didn't know
that yeah
here come the man in black
wow all right so you want to get into
the [ __ ] shits i want to get directly
into the [ __ ] brought to you by
super cult studios click and like the
chris
listener chris evans caller this guy's
the [ __ ] i've been watching since day
one big fan day one was two weeks ago my
question is
about
[ __ ] a roommate do you [ __ ] your
roommate oh my god thought of it right
then chris evans and thor
had a baby that can get complicated
uh
so sexy
so turning us on hypothetically let's
begin sleeping with my roommate and
she's
become emotionally involved despite
uh being forward about intentions and so
what have you and
and
yeah
thanks guys being so
intentions dude being so casual my
question is it had to be quiet because
his roommate's in the other room no dude
she's sucking him while he's doing it
and he didn't want to you want her to
know that he's doing the video the
question is
about [ __ ] your roommate so what's
the deal with that um
so i'm talking about how much was that
guys i'm getting sucked by her right now
dude that's bill clinton that guy was
basically bill clinton you know what he
is honestly question should have been
which marvel avenger am i because he was
in between thor and also captain america
he actually really was um you're usually
wrong but that was right i'm not usually
wrong um so here's the thing about what
this guy's asking about here's the thing
about what this guy's saying he [ __ ]
up so bad yeah yeah yeah and everyone in
the entire [ __ ] universe knows that
yeah in the marvel universe apparently
except him what do you mean because that
was obviously a bad idea to do it though
so he did it already he did it already
okay
he said what do you mean oh cause she
got mostly involved yes people get
mostly involved before they even [ __ ]
but that was obviously going to happen
with one of them one of them was
obviously going to get more emotionally
involved in the other one right because
of obvious
life living
because of obvious life living this was
obviously going to happen
all you had to do was look at
obvious life livings of everyone that's
ever lived a life wow and you would know
that some this is going to be a bad
[ __ ] idea
i don't even want to give him advice he
[ __ ] did the dumb thing but guys are
stupid though dude
if you're a roommate and she's gonna be
walking around obviously in not many
clothes because they're roommates and
she's gotta get ready and he's gonna
catch a glimpse of her [ __ ] you know
what i mean walking by with the door
open and he's just gonna go like huh
and then he's gonna one day just be so
stupid and drunk why don't you like
[ __ ] i'm sorry your hand is a boner
and you're cool but you're a [ __ ]
that is so dumb no but here's the thing
though it happens all the time and
somebody's probably gonna wind up dead
but the main thing is
you just basically have to
not ever [ __ ] your roommate ever it's oh
unless you're prepared to move because
you gotta move now yeah and guess what
you gotta move no matter what you to
either move if you work out or don't
work out if you don't work out whania
has to move right obviously if you do
work out you still got to move because
she's never going to be happy with the
[ __ ] place that you have because it's
probably too small and it was for
roommates exactly not for loving living
yes yes it's a deeper and it's all good
but that's the truth so that is the
truth yeah so you [ __ ] up honestly
shave and go into the witness protectors
program
dude don't
don't [ __ ] ever
just leave leave leave the country
leave the country come to america
because you're obviously in canada
a boot dude that guy also thickest
canadian also the beard just so canadian
yeah but um also wore carhartt which is
[ __ ] super popular in canada up up
super north he's so canadian he like
carries around an axe in case he needs
to chop wood yeah and he never has a
shirt on even when it's snowing
but he has that hat on it's like the guy
from the simpsons yeah yeah yeah um all
right so uh yeah dude you [ __ ] up but
if the advice is what do you do now
you have two options one
move but that's the obvious option
you're gonna move two just be real about
it be like i think we made a mistake is
there any way we could go back to the
way it was before obviously the answer's
gonna be no but there's a slim chance
it's yes but those are your only two
[ __ ] options you
you did a bad bad bad mistake chris
isaac
baby did a bad bad thing isn't that that
precise song baby bad bad so i
i think that he also it's too bad that
we're not in a sci-fi movie because he
could wipe her memory and then just
[ __ ] walk around and be like we
didn't [ __ ] here come the men in black
every song you sing is exact the note is
exactly the same no matter the galaxy
defenders
okay
back um so yeah dude you [ __ ] up get
out of it unless you love her if you
obviously if you are into her then just
continue the relationship right
yeah but you're you made a really bad
mistake
that that's good when i do that that is
one of the good things that song
precisely had two good songs on that set
dude wicked game in that auto wicked
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow this jeez on your dress
in the oval office
hillary
i'm so sad
such sadly back in the 90s
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] dude
[Music]
same it's exactly the same arkansas and
alabama's exactly the same
so rude what you did
alabama that what's the end of the part
at the end of the song where he just
starts talking alabama in arkansas
he doesn't do that
you should completely make another isaac
does it no he doesn't at the end of the
game he just starts at the end he just
goes he's just like kind of trails off
and it's the end of the song and the
girls running at the beach oh yeah yeah
yeah i do it
helena christians running at the beach
or whatever her name is that video left
a real impression on me yeah i know or
you know
you too or you know no i i know it did
to people but it didn't to me why not
um i was already knowing what sex was at
that point
so what
you don't have to not know what sex is
to to be have an impression left the
definition of an impression
um yeah but uh it was good i just that
she that lady is not really my type you
know she was absolutely beautiful
yesterday beautiful most beautiful woman
i know she is and not my type so sue me
also i'm going to take you to court
bill clinton
as evidence [ __ ] linda tripp noah
everyone thought monica was a [ __ ] now
20 years later they all think it's my
fault
the same thing happened
but opinions are different nothing
changed except people's minds that's so
weird
where's lyrics no news about it
all right let's do the next one
hi chris and matt big fan of the podcast
i just wanted to ask you guys for some
advice so
i moved in with my boyfriend this past
december we've been together for three
years now
and the only issue that i've had since
we've moved in together is that i am
really the only person that cleans or
buys anything for this house
he does give me money for stuff and like
we split the bill but
i want help like i don't want to be the
one that always has to go to the grocery
store or the one that always has to
clean everything
and i don't want to be naggy i don't
want to have to
ask him to do everything i don't want to
be his mom but at the same time i don't
feel like i should be doing everything
by myself
and
i just want him to be more like
self-aware of the things in this home so
do you guys have any advice so that way
i'm not the naggy girlfriend but also
too not doing everything myself thanks
guys i've got a great i i it's
interesting because here's the thing i
have to say
your boyfriend is me yeah that's what i
was going to say yeah so maybe he should
stay out of this one and literally er
that's the that's almost that's so
age-old that [ __ ] that age-old
[ __ ] thing about how it's like the
dude is the dude and he doesn't do what
i say
well you know he doesn't clean yeah
exactly which is she wants help dude
my friends me dude
that's a [ __ ] red flag if there ever
was one yeah yeah yeah your boyfriend's
him
don't wanna clean
okay
okay
okay so i think there's some cash don't
worry about being the nagging girlfriend
that is an unfair box
like
if you if you're worried about being
that you're not gonna be that like
that's this is kind of like a box that
women get put in they get called the
nagging girlfriend when like yeah they
want a guy to pick up dirty socks and
the guy's like i don't wanna why are you
nagging me and it's like because your
socks are [ __ ] disgusting they're not
though probably no they're always
disgusting any sock that's been on the
foot for an hour or more is disgusting
they're not eating it it's just there on
the floor it's disgusting to be there on
the ground it's fine no
anyway uh just tell them be like yo pick
up [ __ ] after yourself and go get
some [ __ ] sometimes no
what do you mean no
eat it that's it eat the sock nope just
eat it eat the eat
eat
the
whole deal just shut the [ __ ] up just re
dude
he does what what does he do that's good
right he probably does lots of things
that are good that's why she's with them
there you go so why would we complain
dude you're moving together what did he
do before before they moved in together
well he probably kept his place dirty as
[ __ ] because that's what he wanted and
then he kept his what cupboards
completely bare i i don't know no i bet
he went [ __ ] grocery shopping how
about how about this though kristen said
why don't you just because i leave my
[ __ ]
places yes our place is not a mess no i
leave my [ __ ] place why is it not a mess
kristen no i i do do some tidying up but
i will say this she said why don't you
just
do the dishes always do the dishes and
that can be your thing and i'll do
everything else and i say but the dishes
are the grossest part and she says
exactly so say okay so i do the dishes
mostly all the time right um i should do
them probably all the time but i have
been making a conscious effort for why
don't you delegate [ __ ] right that's a
good idea delegate [ __ ] like i'll pick
up the [ __ ]
and you do the [ __ ] grocery shopping
come up with things that he that you do
that he wouldn't mind doing or will
think of doing yeah and then he can do
that all right because like if he's
never going to get groceries he's never
going to clean up after himself right
you got to figure out other things that
he can do 100 of the time like i'm gonna
i don't want kristen to hear this but
like if she asked me to do laundry some
of the time i would do it because i
actually like doing whispering is it
gonna make a difference you're on a show
that goes out to the entire world doing
the laundry kind of
right but like i would do it if she
asked me i would do it more but i don't
want her to ask me to do it more because
sometimes i mostly want to do other [ __ ]
kristin ask chris to do laundry what a
wicked thing to do if you ask me to do
laundry i
go on the road and make
so find out [ __ ] that he can do that he
can think of on his own that he doesn't
need to be reminded of or nagged about
and then you have the things that you do
he has the things that he does and
hopefully it ends up close to 50 dude if
i was him and she said will you [ __ ]
shop more or [ __ ] clean up more i go
like this i'll bring home the bacon and
do a spin move what if he doesn't bring
him well then he's yeah that's bad dude
that's just like she probably brings
home some bacon too though that's so
old-fashioned yeah i don't know i know
but i'm all the fashion i know you are
but i'm trying to say for [ __ ] her
okay she's in a new age this isn't just
a show for you to talk about you these
people call in and have advice they seek
advices yeah true okay okay
all right so yeah delegation that's what
it's all about yeah and i thought of
that one okay next yep yep
hey guys so
following situation
michael i'm a piano teacher i give
one-on-one lessons is he michael buble
what the [ __ ] is it i have one student
um since the beginning of the year pause
it
um
what what is he holding a microphone
that's a microphone doesn't need it well
maybe he [ __ ] does i mean he's so
obviously russian turn it up okay okay
okay turn it up okay okay
uh that's not the right one
start start it over though yeah we're
gonna start over baby
go ahead here we go
hey guys
so
following situation
um i'm a piano teacher i give one-on-one
lessons
and i have one student
since the beginning of the year
which i really like
i flirt with her she flirts with me poor
boy and
one student she's seductive with her
eyes
oh there's
really something going on there wow and
i want to make the next move
but
she's uh wearing a lot of rings
especially on on this fella how many
one is what matters
polygamist yeah your pirates she's
flirting so much that it seems like she
wants more
so
i don't want to ruin any marriage but i
want to find out if she's really married
married or not
maybe she's a widow i don't know
so i want to find out in a conversation
um maybe you have some um
suggestions
some tricks
some moves i could make
how to find out in a subtle way
my best move so far is
not very subtle it's very
confrontational asking here by the way
is this um engagement ring
and if she might say yes why
then i could say i only wanted to find
out how much flirting is appropriate
that's my best move so far maybe you
have some ideas for me robots that would
be
very great
um
yeah much much love from germany hell
yeah thanks for doing this
um yeah goodbye doing
i mean
dude all right
well that the whole thing
just uh there's a lot of ways we could
start this one i don't know what it's
like in germany but in america and if
you're the teacher yeah you can't
yeah you know this is your job first
things first you don't this guy dude i
don't [ __ ] her yeah i have had i no
hello i have one student since the
beginning of say yeah i don't know that
i would like to [ __ ] her
that was a language very thing ruin my
business yeah
in germany it is tradition to ruin your
whole business
he met one of his students okay not as a
language barrier thing so so is the word
confrontational the thing i do is very
confrontational i say do you have a
husband or are you a video dude
supposing that the husband died is so
german dude i mean is how is she [ __ ]
65 dude i mean like did your husband die
dude
okay this i mean there is so much to
[ __ ] unpack i think first of all what
i'm curious about is if she has a lot of
rings on on that finger it's johnny depp
just ask
why do you have so many what's up with
that one finger you have so many dude
her hands are just so heavy when she
comes in one hand is leaning down
because it's the one finger yeah the
wedding finger he's talking about so go
so she said she has so many rings yeah
so maybe she's a [ __ ] carny and she
just like has rings all over but you
should say take off your rings take off
your rings to play the piano it's easier
take off your engagement ring and if she
says oh it's not it's not an engagement
ring hahaha and he goes haha and then
going for a kiss
that's a little tricky wrong all over
the piano it's a little tricky though
because i know you you don't want to be
like a sleaze roundabout just just you
know ask but in a plain way like a
non-confrontational way just be like i
noticed you have a lot of rings on that
one finger what
what's that rank the ranked rings in
order from one to nine no but okay
here's what i say don't [ __ ] her
obviously okay if you're if you want to
explore a love thing let's go from this
okay
all you got to do
is say
i mean add it to the [ __ ] uh
lesson like if you're playing like
picture your husband you love him very
much right like this your husband what's
his name
she says either greg then you know you
got a husband okay greg you love greg
and you playing for craig
if she says oh i don't have one then go
like this i
oh really
so that's very nice and then play and
then you know dude
but how much flirting is appropriate
like you're [ __ ] kind of flirt bot
2000 kind of none though hello how are
you
how much flirt before we commence less
and i've noticed you have nine rings i
don't know which one is an engagement
ring however which how much flirtings
is appropriate
with the microphone still
it doesn't need it didn't even use it
that's the only one dude he has a
microphone and this was the only one
that you said turn it up yeah true
doesn't need it dude or needed it more
and held it too far everything on that
guy is beige dude his skin his lips his
nose his hair his eyes everything's
beige
his shirt was based he was a robot he is
a robot beige dude maybe it's different
in germany as you pointed out but just
don't don't ever [ __ ] your student yeah
okay i have one student i'm trying to
ruin my business i'd like to slide in
and out of her bicycle
dude
dude
the one i don't know what move i should
do but the move i have is very
confrontational i put a gun on her
and i say do are you [ __ ] married or
not
i say hands up student are you married
or not
yeah if she says yes i shoot her
what did he say did he say he did that
his move already or he's thinking about
he's thinking about doing the move
there's no move don't yeah don't there
is exactly there is no move but do it
nicely dude germans are very you know
what i mean direct and this is what i
want but like dude just [ __ ] play
around like your little like you're you
know like you're you could add it in the
lesson do you love your husband very
much but that's a separate thing good
okay then if there's no move and there's
if there's no move to be made because he
shouldn't do it then are you saying he
still wants to find out if she's married
or not because that's that could be two
separate things yeah yeah yeah no i
thought he wanted to find out if she's
married or not because if it's a fake
engagement or if she's not married or if
it's just a ring among many rings and
it's not an engagement ring then he
would feel okay to make the move
but if she is getting engaged it sounds
like he still wants to also see if it's
that serious because he could do that
[ __ ] stop thinking about doing that [ __ ]
yeah yeah well at some point the lessons
will probably end
and at that point when things are not on
a professional basis
maybe you can explore but if you want to
know about the details before that might
happen
i guess that's fair but don't [ __ ] do
[ __ ] or teach songs that are obvious
about what if she is engaged obvious
what you want to do do you know what i
mean you could be like we're going to
learn this today's wicked game
just two notes so it's like so obvious
you're not even learning right
whatever game we play
when you're absolutely married but do
some shady sings with your piano teacher
just per se plays out
ding ding said it
sing she [ __ ] up piano teacher
she has
[Laughter]
are you engaged
[Laughter]
goddamn oh my god is it a real
engagement so if the answer is yes how
serious is it would you explore
cramming so many words in between
would you explore doing a horizontal
wow okay what do we get game we play you
come over to learn piano and i got a
boner no hi
all right i'm so [ __ ] beige so don't
make a move don't make it is the
solution here yeah don't make a move
okay next
i apparently drive my soon-to-be fiance
insane with the way i microwave my food
i push the 30 second button over and
over
because it's [ __ ] expedient and i
stand by the microwave and i check to
make sure it's not too hot or not too
cold and if it needs to stay in there
longer it [ __ ] stays in there longer
it's not that big of a deal but she
draws issue with the fact that she has
to get up and push the cancel button so
that it displays the time again
and i'm just don't don't do that how
about learn to live with it
i don't know what do you think
so this guy what is it this guy i do
that too he's saying instead of putting
in its own uh uh a single time
you just repeatedly hit the 30 second
button oh
and pay attention as it's heating up
okay and then you only go by that so if
you want to heat it for like a minute
and a half and you know that and then
you want to keep an eye on it
yeah
and why
and then if you decide you want it for
two minutes dude right two and a half
minutes and it bothers her because of
what she's making too much noise
i think she wants the single time like
the confidence of the single move well
that's not her heating up the food and i
think it bothers her that he like lurks
around the microwave and no that's not
what he said okay then what is it she
wants to have the time on the display
not like 23 seconds left why though
yeah that's cool he's right i mean she's
she's yeah that doesn't have a weird
complaint that doesn't matter that's
weird for her if she's gonna be
this guy was so hot he was so hot right
there he came in he was like she was
okay
about it yep and she was like don't do
the video and then she went into target
and he did the video um
yeah that's uh if if that's the issue
well that first of all that's not the
issue it's got to be
i mean that's cr that's really that's
not an issue how about that yay we found
one that's absolutely not an issue
finally yay no the issue is hers why
does she have a problem with it yeah
that's he's right
that's a weird [ __ ] complaint yeah
that is a weird complaint i mean of all
the things to complain about your
partner like
yeah imagine like all the things you
kind of sat on and never told your
various ex-girlfriends like how many
[ __ ] things
are better than that oh man it's such a
non-thing those i i eat those all day
you know right you gotta eat those all
day just little snacks
all day i'm just like don't do okay well
i don't want to it's not worth it okay
exactly okay well i don't and then
that's how it becomes it becomes cancer
eventually that's why everyone dies from
cancer because that because and she had
the girl to say that one yeah that's
crazy are there other things that are
wrong there's got to be so many things
that are wrong but that's a hilarious
one what if there's so few
that this is the only one she can really
come up with then this is the perfect
couple of all the time
that's the advice you have the greatest
relationship you have the greatest
relationship of all time and have a kid
and that kid grows up and becomes it's
jesus christ the most well adjusted yeah
beautiful
child that's amazing dude yeah that's
great dude congratulations this guy's
got the greatest relationship
your upcoming wedding good job and show
the show this video to your girlfriend
and about how this hey don't do that to
him let him do you know what let him do
it let him do it
or how about this you heat up the food
it's his food he wants heat up the food
for him though but he wants to do it his
way
yeah what the [ __ ] dude you can't
control the temperature of his food man
wow
okay you got you you're getting hot but
you can't though you know what's getting
hot his food exactly the way he wants it
yeah because he gets to [ __ ] ride the
time and i don't ride the time i always
put in i do a minute and a half oh i
ride the time dude i just
i coast on the time that's stupid but
what about come all right all the time
whoo and riding whoo
so bad okay yeah no it's not your fault
bro it's not your fault it's like that
scene in uh goodwill hunting his night
fault and he starts
[Music]
[Laughter]
god damn it greg in the back
why is everybody greg today you pick one
in your role with it okay okay next one
hey magical i was hoping i could get
your advice on something with only my
friend and uh chris i guess you could
throw your opinion in there too
he and i are both pretty anti-social
people and it's hard for us to find a
time where we both want to spend time
with one another soon i'm going to be
going away to college and that's his
boyfriend many hours away so i was
hoping you guys could give me some
advice on how i could find a way to
spend time with him you talk about his
boyfriend who's he talking about best
friend oh can you
uh
i kind of i was unclear about that from
the beginning you play that one again
actually
yeah
hey matt i was hoping i could get your
advice on something with my best friend
and uh chris i guess you could throw
your opinion in there too
uh he and i are both pretty anti-social
people and it's hard for us to find a
time where we both want to spend time
with one another soon i'm going to be
going away to college and that's going
to take me many hours away so i was
hoping you guys could give me some
advice on how i could find a way to
spend time with him you guys gotta [ __ ]
that's tough because you
i mean when i think of anti-social
behavior i think of like you don't want
to like go to [ __ ] parties yeah and
be with big groups right but
as a sometimes a very often anti-social
person myself right i
i will often be
not consider
that like one-on-one [ __ ] one-on-one
[ __ ] is kind of better and if if the
issue is
you're anti-social and he's anti-social
so you don't want to hang out with each
other and it's hard to find times to
just want to be around a living human
body that's a little bit trickier i
don't know but like
i would say that just make sure it's
a thing that the both of you want to do
and that it's just you guys and that
there's no like
next thing that you guys are going to go
to
like an uh a [ __ ] party or whatever
like no other people being invited make
sure it's like a [ __ ] chill relaxed
environment that like isn't going to be
interfered with by others
no he needs the metaverse what's that
mean he needs to just plug into the
metaverse and find some [ __ ] what do
they call the you know they go to build
a place in the metaverse have the guy
people meet this is what anti-social
people do they get hooked into the
metaverse and they just chill out dude
what is it what are you saying it's like
the matrix man you just [ __ ] put on
some vr goggles and you go into the
metaverse and you chill out and you
[ __ ] so they share a space in the
metaverse yeah they could even though
they're alone
that's something well you're alone yeah
no i guess nobody is ever actually
really in the metaverse i know so you're
alone and you go into the metaverse and
you do whatever you want and you meet up
with that dude and maybe you have a
house with that guy in the metaverse but
how do you
[ __ ] each other it's not even gay how do
you have how do you meet up with someone
in the metaverse what does that mean
your avatar meets another person's
avatar can you plan to meet somewhere
yeah you can yeah or like text them in
the metaverse i guess i don't really
know how it goes i'm not anti-social but
you can go do that i think you could
[ __ ] each other even if you're both guys
that's not gay what i would suggest
first and foremost though is don't force
it and because you feel like you have a
clock on it like this idea of like oh no
i'm leaving for college i'm not going to
be able to see him a lot i want to hang
out with him i want to hang out with him
i want to hang out with him you might
just end up making it weird not just for
him but also for yourself right also
weird pressure on yourself and him yeah
but you're going to end up hanging out
with him again you'll be home from
college sometimes yeah you'll [ __ ]
meet up
you know it's up to you guys but also
the
don't think of college as the end of
something right it's not plus also the
meta versus no matter where you are no
matter where you are you can hook into
your avatar and meet up with whoever the
[ __ ] you want and be antisocial in the
metaverse but with someone else and
technically you're still anti-social
you'll be at a party and still be
antisocial because you're the metaverse
you're not actually doing it that's why
if you both of you him and his friend go
back home and [ __ ] each other it's not
even gay so
two things
why do you keep on bringing up the
metaverse he didn't do that and why do
you keep mentioning [ __ ] him in the
metaverse i'm suggesting be in the
metaverse because you can get out all of
the [ __ ] things that you want to
both ways anti-socially and also
socially because you're still being
anti-social when you're in the metaverse
because it doesn't really count in real
life which is why i'm saying if they
[ __ ] each other it doesn't count as
being gay it seems like you're adding
the last part about [ __ ] for
absolutely no reason but
that's okay i guess these guys need to
yeah it's uh if also dude you know what
is he going to college so here's the
other thing yes um
you're not gonna be probably friends
with this guy anyway in five years so
it's fine that might be true but it that
doesn't see you can't say that though
because
him now
is friends with him like you can't be
like don't worry about it it's like you
can't tell the kid like right that's
true problem that you are crying over
that's true when you're [ __ ] 20 isn't
going to matter worth [ __ ] no you can't
really say that that's true dude but i
am gonna say that as a father i mean you
would be right but
yeah it's gonna [ __ ] up the kids i think
that honestly uh it'll be uh yeah i
don't i
i mean the other guy are they worried
about the relationship
what's this guy worried about is the
other guy worried he wants to hang
get the mac that's what i was saying
before about there being a clock on it
yeah he wants to make sure he maximizes
their potential time together before he
moves hours away
it's a weird dichotomy though because he
wants to hang out with the guy but he
also it was saying i'm an anti-social
but
if he's anti-social and he's okay with
it then why does he want to be [ __ ]
social
yeah maybe maybe you just need to be
maybe you're you are not that
anti-social yeah you might not be maybe
he is maybe the other guy is yeah in
which case try to [ __ ] get him into
the metaverse just tell him dude like
i'm leaving soon like let's hang as much
as much as you can and as much as you're
down like let's hang because i'm around
and i really want to hang with you
before i go as much as we can
yeah bada-boom that's good that's good
advice yeah
okay
next
hey what's up guys my name is mitch i
love the show
every episode's been great dude oh yeah
i'm a huge fan of both of you guys keep
doing what you're doing and get your dad
on the show
please anyways
body odor oh that's the question body
odor when someone has it someone you
work with every single day someone
that's right next to you all day long do
you tell them do you not tell them oh
dude do you just plug the snazz and keep
on trucking or what do i do dude
because my partner at work
has a stench oh
and it
is terrible yeah i don't know what to do
please help guys thanks huge fan love
you guys
see you thanks bro
you know you know what uh it's tough
because you got to be careful with that
[ __ ] because you can get like sued in
the workplace for [ __ ] like that
but yeah be like yo you stink you gotta
[ __ ] put on deodorant you get sued
for that he's not gonna say that that's
the way he's calling in that's what i'm
saying so we talk about the things you
do do and the things that you don't do
so don't do that okay right especially
if he's [ __ ]
his boss which he says he's his partner
so maybe not maybe you know what they
are they made their detectives right
um maybe they're in like a pod together
he can't get away yeah yeah which is
awful um
[ __ ] man walk in with a [ __ ] one of
those things like a [ __ ]
clothespin and then i'd be like what are
you doing and be like what do you mean
yeah yeah well you have a nose right you
smell yourself
so what the [ __ ] what what are you
asking do everything short of telling
him that he is
that's uh terrible i mean maybe like
body odor doesn't bother me i'm french
dude really yeah are you crazy i don't
care
why
it doesn't bother me body odor smell how
you smell can you tell yep there was one
time that i would hang out with somebody
and they had horrible body odor and i
could not take it but only one time i've
smelled body odor sometimes it just
smells like a sandwich you know what i
mean they smell like a sandwich or like
onions
disgusting i don't care man i don't
yep i don't care man i don't give a [ __ ]
bad breath
i'm on the [ __ ] highway i'm out of
here dude bad breath is awful they're
the same thing
i know but one is on the outside and it
feels superficial and one is on the
inside if you have bad body odor that's
fine you can watch it if you have bad
breath that's inside you that's who you
are
that's who your soul is your soul stinks
like [ __ ] body odor is who you are but
i'm french about that man okay well
you're not french about [ __ ] breath
no because that's who you are no you
made that up entirely french people have
body odor they don't have bad breath
dude you want bad breath you go to like
[ __ ] i mean i don't want to say it
but you know you know i don't know
halitosis is not regional buddy i know
that but like sometimes when you
some korean guys when they're going oh
okay wow there's a [ __ ]
there's a
there's a weird thing too where your
your sense of smell for someone the way
your nose interacts with someone else
can actually change over time yep and i
wouldn't bank on that i wouldn't bank on
your nose just suddenly being okay with
this [ __ ] co-worker especially now
that it's lodged in your head but
i used to
be around someone someone i dated uh who
smelled great in the beginning of my
relationship and then as it soured as
the relationship got worse i swear at
the end
she smelled like cat piss but do you
know why you know why that happened
though honestly actual cap i know i know
it's because i didn't like her and then
after you guys started dating a little
bit i would take cat piss i put under
your nose oh dad yeah you ruined it
you're like
a cat piss dude cat piss
cat piss
has it been the other way sometimes it
has been the other way i used to hang
out with a guy who had bad smells and
then i realized oh it's not so bad and i
don't know if i changed or he changed
her butt
i'm not getting not i mean just yeah
friends probably got used to it yeah
maybe i don't know
well i would say oh [ __ ] man you're
[ __ ] yeah get a new job get get get
relocate shave go in the witness
production during the black plague you
know they had those long masks oh yeah
they put the they put flowers and citrus
juice oh is that what it was in the big
nose thing yeah really so they wouldn't
smell the dead bodies all the time oh
dude that's what that long dick knows
thing was then why did they do that for
like sex parties
they
it got crossed you know wow dude in
[ __ ] eyes wide shut yeah that's yeah
exactly ding ding ding ding that's my
favorite movie score of all time okay
one thing is that german teacher ding
ding ding ding ding
speaking ding ding
ding ding
worse best song to get stuck in your
head but worse on youtube
speaking of eyes wide shot yeah baby did
a bad bad thing is oh yeah dude it all
comes full circle dude imagine having
that song stuck in your head walking on
the feet just ding ding
just tourette syndrome at the bank
chris oh yeah yeah yeah what's up you
don't have to sing the song that's stuck
in your head that loud
the two best songs in the world are in
that
movie not bad bad thing they go ding
ding ding the score and also the [ __ ]
when they're [ __ ] dude
oh the gregorian chance yeah dude
gregorian champions
i love it dude i do like gregorian
chances
yeah i know what you know what i'm
saying that part
uh
[ __ ] what was it of the smell uh dude
imagine the strawberry sex party try
like lighting [ __ ] candles lighting
incense bring those sam what are those
things called the little pieces of wood
palo santo palo santo yes
they're gonna get it light them no i'm
happy i know what the name is now
[ __ ] okay
um
light them in the office around the
[ __ ] and then sex party and then
when the guy asks
say
because it smells like [ __ ] in here you
don't smell that
you can like be really forceful about it
smelling like [ __ ] and then maybe he'll
get the idea like oh
is it me
because then the guy will be like
he'll he can see like oh i don't smell
it what does it smell like he goes i
don't know it smells like [ __ ] bodies
or something like like gross
with onions yeah something like gross
body odor or but you don't have to say
it's you yeah you know you know what you
could do
go in with the candles and that [ __ ]
big dick nose with the flowers in it
yeah he'll be like what the [ __ ] is his
eyes wide shut and then be like nah dude
you know what man you don't smell that
and he'll be like nah and then take your
dick nose off and be like there's this
weird smell in here and it's been in
here for a while and then go around the
room and just be like
yeah
and i go lift up the stapler wow like
go on to him go and then go to his
armpit and go like this
and then go like this
[Laughter]
and [ __ ] faint fake faint and then be
like and then wake up and be like what
the [ __ ] just happened yeah he'll be too
embarrassed yeah he'll be like i don't
know and then he'll get the hint that
it's his [ __ ] onion turkey sandwich
[ __ ] army damn it i don't even like
when you say it ding it ding
ding
[Music]
hurting your [ __ ] thighs so bad dude
those are the final thrusts though um
all right well i guess we got this guy
covered yeah do it
all right next one
hey matt and chris this is uh richard
i'm a longtime fan of you guys i've been
a fan of congratulations since like uh
episode 100. oh yeah i think it's great
i love what you guys do you're so funny
my question is pretty easy um
i'm like 22 years old i graduated
college recently i've moved into a house
i'm starting a job soon and i think i've
got a handle on myself in my adult life
but um
my family actually gets on me really
hard about um my hair
growing my beard out and my hair and my
family just says it looks unprofessional
everyone they're telling me to cut it
always and i think you guys can agree
that that's like it's my hair it's my
job to like take care of it and take
good care of it and it's not like a
thing to be ashamed of or whatever but
how do you think i could get them to see
reason because you guys i think would
agree that that's just like
kind of an annoying question to always
have to be answering like when are you
getting engaged or when are you going to
have kids yeah it's just like it's my
body and my hair and i want to do what i
want to do with it so thank you guys bye
first of all i already got a [ __ ] job
so who cares he has a job his life's
going fine what do you mean professional
professional what also that's [ __ ]
old school i was just going to say what
how old are these are they only your
parents probably because that is so
old-school to think that way you could
[ __ ] have any hair and yeah any job
dude you could be a doctor if you wanted
yeah i mean a hundred percent yeah yeah
i mean
a certain kind of doctor you could be
operating with that [ __ ] you know yeah
yeah although if you tied it up [ __ ] it
yeah no he's just like [ __ ] forceps
put his [ __ ] beard away um first of
all yeah i mean i don't know man that's
just annoying man your family that's so
annoying here's what i think they say
it's not professional but what they just
what they mean all they mean is they
want you to [ __ ] cut it they don't
like it yeah they don't like it but yeah
but again [ __ ] them
like it's your [ __ ] head dude never
cut your hair because someone else says
you should
never do that
do the opposite hey you should get your
hair cut now it's going longer yeah
anytime you say it it's going longer oh
you add an inch you want to add another
inch hey dad yeah do you hear mom mom
just added an inch that's two inches for
you guys you both agreed
and the beard's going longer great great
yeah exactly yeah dude that's annoying
as [ __ ] it's your hair it's your hair or
shave it completely and honestly say and
be like i hope you're happy yeah and and
say like and then say you did it because
[ __ ] of the area nation and you and
do it put
no
a
swastika
just saying these are all [ __ ] great
advice no that's a terrible bit of
advice okay because then no one wins you
know well except the aryan nation and
that's not good master race that's not
good
okay
you agree actually yeah you're acting
yeah okay i agree
the german guy the piano teacher
probably agrees no not every german is a
nazi i know
do you
no hey chris hey matt my name
i'm keeping short and sweet for you guys
i just want to know how does one
speak highly of themselves without
sounding arrogant
thanks for keeping it real and making me
laugh
oh well i mean just talk about yourself
and then when somebody says like
oh you sound arrogant be like oh no
that's what the [ __ ]
new york times says oh
no um i don't know
that's interesting
hmm oh you know what you got to do you
got to balance it out with yeah dumb
[ __ ] about you yeah right bad [ __ ] like
um honest bad [ __ ] yeah yeah like you
know me like yeah i've got this mustache
and it's terrible but also i'm great at
hockey
right but also it needs to be in context
like
you don't say great [ __ ] about yourself
out of the blue
and if you're if you sometimes it helps
to preface like when you say something
good about yourself like i look i know
how this is gonna sound like you [ __ ]
make fun of me if you want but it's true
and then you say the thing you can't
just be like i'm the [ __ ] you know what
i know how this is gonna sound and i get
it but i am great at hockey yeah that
would be
not as good it mostly seems listening to
what i'm saying it mostly seems pretty
arrogant but honestly dude sometimes
it's like
look the fact that you're even really
thinking about this probably means it's
okay and you're not full of yourself
yeah exactly um but also it's like why
do you want to say good stuff about
yourself
it's got to be in some kind of context
that we're not aware of that we're not
getting that for him comes up from time
to time like i think maybe what he's
asking is like how do you check how do
you like
advocate for yourself
without coming off as cocky
um
but i don't know maybe i'm putting words
in his mouth it sounds like it's just
chick what like you just you know you're
always like and he's just like this is
why you like me though i'm good at
hockey and steeper deeper issues wow
i don't know man i think that there's a
line you know you just [ __ ] you
pepper in a few look
how about this man
treat it as if someone else is talking
about you yeah they say the they see the
good and the bad right you're talking
about someone else yeah what
treat it as if you're talking about
science exactly right right right right
um yeah be like you know yeah
well you know i'm good at hockey you
know you know that guy
yeah but also
his legs are short you don't actually
put it in the third person though
you go like that guy
but
not me that guy just end up pointing at
yourself
i i think uh
i don't i don't know this is something i
don't worry about maybe it means i'm
conceited
i do i do say things that are about me
that are good but i also say things
about me that are terrible which is why
people will listen to you yeah if you
say it too much say too many good things
people be like [ __ ] that guy yeah
rightfully so right what's the [ __ ]
point uh of listening to somebody who's
just talking about how great they are
yeah but uh yeah also i would say just
i the advice that i'm i gave is i think
is the right advice but i think just to
be
have a little bit of caution about
there's a certain kind of thing
that you just shouldn't bring up about
yourself regardless of how you preface
it or anything like what
i don't know like well certainly how
much [ __ ] money you have is a good
thing like there's certainly somebody
was talking about just in bad taste i
got crazy money how do i talk about how
much money i have because i have a lot
of it without sounding arrogant
you guys know money right oh yeah yeah
okay so how much do you guys have
oh you have that much oh okay oh never
mind then you do that but why
no because i was just wondering what was
like normal
because i went more than that but it's
it's fine
it's fine um my [ __ ] is like actually
you know what's funny is you know how
they keep uh bank accounts you can
access your bank account on your app at
your phone
um my phone's it's heavier because of
how much money is in my app on my phone
wow yeah but anyway dude anyway what
were we talking about
yeah what else what else can you not
talk about i think this is like uh this
is like a uh
you either know how to do it or you
don't kind of thing
you know because there's such a [ __ ]
it's not that fine of a line between
boasting and just talking yeah so like
if you have a if you perceive that as to
be a very thin line then like i don't
know what to [ __ ] tell you maybe you
shouldn't say it um yeah i like the
money i like the money conversation i
like that well i got i brought that
there's another way you can do it here's
another way you could do it and it would
be okay to talk about how much money you
have okay who's your favorite cartoon
character who do you like that's cartoon
character i like uh
pepe le pew oh that's funny mine is
[ __ ] scrooge mcduck i love how he
[ __ ] has so much money do you know
what's weird i'm like him
[Laughter]
and they'd be like why because you never
wear pants and be like no no no no cause
all the money he has awesome duck tales
my favorite is actually michigan j frog
not pepe the people yeah i was in a
character i was playing someone i don't
know
me too okay
um he goes hello hello my darling hell
i'm a rectum gal yeah and he does the
top hat
yeah yeah yeah and he's a frog i know
that oh okay that's why his name is
michigan j frog he's from michigan you
could have the last name frog and not be
a frog obviously
okay okay okay well is that it i guess
we're done
do you guys want to be done you wanna do
another one sure okay let's do another
one
gentlemen how are we
brett i'm in hands australia huge fan of
the podcast chris i've been a fan since
day one love you both keep doing what
you're doing
i've got some advice that i need from
you guys medication as an adult i was
diagnosed with adhd at about nine ten
years old uh i was on medication for
about five or six years my mum said it
improved my grades and my behavior i
don't remember it doing so well
i'm 28 now and i'm looking to get back
into study and
i feel like medication would improve
certain things in my life
to do with anxiety
stress all of those kind of things i'd
love to hear your opinion on it
medication as an adult please let me
know what you reckon
um love the podcast keep doing what
you're
doing what is people's aversion to
taking medication old-school [ __ ] man
it's still there's that old way of
thinking this like don't take medication
you know but also australia is like a
little bit behind on the time don't they
get cold later maybe they have a
different view of it but dude take it
yeah dude try it at least i mean talk to
a doctor about it don't like buy it on
the [ __ ] street go to [ __ ]
downtown and get it but like snort it if
a doctor prescribed it for you in the
past and it's an actual clinical problem
that you have ostensibly still then
[ __ ] and you're having potential
trouble on the horizon or experiencing
something that you could be that you
could benefit from being on the same
medicine again what the [ __ ] do it take
it i had yeah yeah i had really bad i
have really bad ocd as you guys know
probably if you're [ __ ] if you listen
to me ever but like i have really bad
ocd and i didn't want to take medication
for the longest time and then finally i
was like if it ever gets in this was
back when i was like 26 something 25 i
was like if it ever gets in the way of
my work i'll start taking medication if
my ocd ever starts getting in way my
work and then one night it did get in
the way of my work and i thought that's
it i remember i gave myself an ultimatum
and i started taking medication the next
day because i already had it i already
had it i just never took it i started
taking medication the next day dude it
[ __ ] really takes the edge off [ __ ]
man like my ocd isn't as bad um i mean i
still struggle with it and i'm still me
you know what i mean sometimes people
aversion to taking medication is i'll
lose myself but you don't dude you
become a better version of yourself i
mean it's 2022 the medication's around
for a reason it's not like everyone's
[ __ ] hoodwinked into taking this [ __ ]
yeah you know um
so yeah i mean i think that it's a good
thing to do why didn't you
why did you have an aversion to taking
it because i thought i was gonna lose
myself here's the thing though and don't
take offense to this you're a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] you're not gonna [ __ ]
you're not that great in the first place
i was great
and you know scrooge mcduck the thing
the thing that everyone is so like
nervous i hear that a lot yeah you're
not that great like you're not the great
great just take this [ __ ] you'll be
better for yourself and everybody else
you're not that [ __ ] great take the
medicine good i was great but yeah and i
am great but yeah wow yeah okay okay so
you're the exception but yeah nah
there's a few exceptions it's like me
[ __ ] tiger woods and jesus but it's
like
you know you don't want to take the [ __ ]
too much [ __ ] and uh but yeah i get it
dude i get it but yeah if it worked for
you when you were 10 and if shit's
getting in the way now if you're mental
[ __ ] then you know
um
try it and try it for three months try
it for four months sometimes it takes a
long time for it to kick in anyway you
probably won't even realize it and if
you've got 80 adhd
yeah yeah eft sucks get on some [ __ ]
talk to a doctor let them [ __ ]
make you feel better i know people with
adhd and dude they don't even know where
they are sometimes what
well i mean not you know i mean not
actually not know where they are but i'm
just saying it's like
they do [ __ ] and you're just like what
the [ __ ] going on and they're like
sorry i i don't and then you get
frustrated it [ __ ] people's lives up
okay well there you go there you go i
can do it
subscribe to the clips channel dude we
put out the clips and [ __ ] share the
clips and share um
share it uh subscribe to super cult
studios on this is where this podcast is
and if you have a question if you have a
question click on the link in the
description below or go to
watchlifeline.com
and uh
you know chrisalia.com for tickets i am
on tour
go
to crystalia.com oh i didn't announce
albany i'm gonna be in albany too but uh
go there and uh
and uh you can get this merch here uh
chrisley.com but anyway
watch lifetime watch lifeline.com for uh
submissions we really enjoyed doing the
show it's been a lot of fun yeah and uh
thanks you guys you guys have merch
coming out soon oh yeah we have merch
coming out too soon too so stick uh
stick around for that we'll be uh
announcing it soon and if all of you
don't buy some of it and put it on and
take pictures and send in your video
submissions with it on
i'm gonna [ __ ] rage and cry every
single day of my life okay you need to
get on medication then but
yeah guys thanks for listening and leave
comments appreciate you
hello hello
[Music]